questions a red zone alk have the rams
gone all in to win the los angeles
market i don't know if shereen's frozen
up there i don't think she has there she
is shireen i hadn't you know i thought
about it initially saturday night and i
hadn't circled back to it but there is
still a competition in los angeles
between the rams and the chargers and
with the chargers having justin herbert
and now they took brandon staley from
the rams i i feel like the rams made
that move to get matthew stafford and
get rid of jared goff in part because
they are concerned at some level that
the tenants in their stadium may take
over
well you see when the charters did last
year with justin herbert they look like
they have their franchise quarterback
which is what you have to have to win
and mike we both think they
underachieved this year i mean anthony
lynn and some of the coaching decisions
he made were not good and so they are
where they are now with the new head
coach and they they look like they're on
the way to some success so the rams have
got to keep up with that and to do that
they had to make a quarterback move but
i'm not convinced mike are you convinced
that matthew stafford is that much
better than jared goff
well
sean mcveigh is and i guess that's all
that matters and sean mcveigh became
fixated on getting stafford it was clear
they wanted to get rid of goff after
five seasons just two years after
getting to the super bowl i'd still love
to know what it was that caused mcveigh
to completely fall out of love with goff
after what they paid him and mcveigh now
thinks he can take stafford a guy who
can make all the throws and turning him
to something that he hasn't been i still
want to know and we'll find out we'll
find out
was it stafford or the lions was it goff
or mcvay in the regression those are all
things that the 2021 maybe 2022 season
will tell us who wins more games next
year shireen the rams are the raiders
well i'm gonna have to go with the rams
mike just because of where they've been
over the last few years and where the
raiders haven't been over the last two
years i mean they've won 19 games the
last three years under john gruden what
makes you think they're going to be any
better next year i guess we'll see in
free agency in the draft but right now
i'd definitely say the rams with that
number one overall defense they're gonna
be in every game
they get a boost from the arrival of
matthew stafford i think it's going to
invigorate the offense and the window's
open for now on the rams to do something
where it's going to be problematic when
those first round picks that they don't
have from 2017 through 2023 would
otherwise be maturing into great players
that's when aaron donald is going to
wear down that's when jalen ramsey is
going to slow down and that's when
matthew stafford is going to be on the
wrong side of 35 and that's when the
rams are going to have their work cut
out for him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports